Gerade wurde bekannt dass die regierung der usa
Jahrelang mit millionenaufwand ufo forschung betrieben hat ist es also gar nicht so abwegig nach ufos zu forschen
Und genau da setzt das projekt
Rostockern hier kann jeder mitmachen und sich als augenzeuge nicht seriöser objekte am himmel
Eintragen die kabel zeigt an wann und wo welche objekte gesichtet worden sind die viele unbekannte flugobjekte allein. Im jahr
2017 registriert worden sind und wo offensichtlich die in den hotspots dieser welt liegen jetzt den klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Die interaktive karte funktioniert ganz einfach wann und wo wurde das unbekannte flugobjekt gesichtet und wie sah es genau aus diese
informationen kann jede augenzeuge auf der website ufo stalker
eingeben wenn möglich dann sogar mit einem beweisfoto dann wird eine fallnummer erstellt und der sichtung sword sowie die
Kommentare des jeweiligen augenzeugen werden ihnen die datenbank eingespeist und es werden tatsächlich daten aus der ganzen welt aufgenommen
Doch user können nicht nur ihre eigenen ufo-sichtungen eingeben sondern sich auch anschauen ob und wann
außerirdische in ihrer
Nähe entdeckt worden sind die ufo symbole der interaktiven karte müssen dafür ganz einfach angeklickt werden und schon werden die mehr oder weniger
Detaillierten berichte angezeigt da heißt es dann zum beispiel in einem bericht vom 18, märz
2017 aus würselen also deutschland nrw
Das objekt war schnell flog im zickzack kurs und leuchtete grünen erst vor kurzem mitte dezember
Wurde ein seltsames objekt in der iranischen stadt sowie sarah gemeldet in dem bericht heißt es
Ich habe es gegen mitternacht vom grundstück meiner oma
Beobachtete sah aus wie eine untertasse und machte keine geräusche es leuchtete blau und es schien so als
Würde es nicht beobachten
erstaunlich bisher sind insgesamt rund
84.000 sichtungen gemeldet wurden allein im jahr 2017 waren es rund
5500 und damit gab es einen anstieg zum vorjahr um etwa acht prozent sind aliens also tatsächlich auf dem vormarsch oder
Beteiligen sich einfach nur sehr viel mehr leute mysteriöse objekte am himmel gesehen zu haben
Ohne frage hat damit sicher auch das in kann es zu tun denn viel arbeit ist es wahrscheinlich nicht dort mal schnell angaben zum mysteriösen
Objekten, am himmel
Zu machen es dauert etwa 10 bis 15 minuten und geht auch anonym
man kann die sichtung aber auch nach beliebigen kriterien filtern zum beispiel nach region monatag oder ja dabei
Scheinen die meisten berichte, im sommer ein so gehen vor allem
Im juli scheinen sich besonders oft seltsame phänomene
Am himmel abzuspielen das objekt basiert auf dem elektronischen fall bearbeitungsprogramm der ufa organisation nur von
case management system wovon steht für
Network und seinen sitz ist in den usa eines der hauptziele die öffentlichkeit
Über das ufo phänomen und die möglichen auswirkungen auf die gesellschaft zu informieren
Wenn eine sicherung eingegeben wird schauen sich danach nur von
Freiwillige foto analysten das beigefügte bildmaterial an so heißt es auf der website
Sie verwenden eine reihe von verschiedenen techniken um die authentizität
des fotos oder videos zu
identifizieren und zu versuchen
Eine meinung darüber abzugeben ob es sich um eine echte oder um eine fälschung handeln und um den ursprung des objekts auf dem foto
Allerdings das projekt ist alles andere als wissenschaftlich schließlich gibt es keine ausschlusskriterien nach denen die meldungen aus gesehen werden jeder wirklich jeder
kann
Berichte eintragen und so ist es natürlich klar dass es sich wenn überhaupt
Bestimmt nicht bei allen meldungen um außerirdische handeln würde selbst wenn
tatsächlich echte ufo-sichtungen dabei werden denn schließlich gibt es viele andere erklärungen für seltsame erscheinungen oder lichter
Am himmel das wetter meteo schauer oder
beispielsweise flugzeug test oder drohen inzwischen als das kann dahinter stecken trotzdem visualisiert die karte natürlich super wann und wo angeblich
Mysteriöse objekte am himmel zu sehen waren spannend dabei oft werden ja karge wüsten gegen den mit alien hotspots
assoziiert doch die karte ufos tor gezeigt dass sich die berichte dort eher auf großstädte und dicht besiedelte
ballungszentren konzentrieren große hotspots sind tatsächlich new york und die umliegenden metropolen genauso wie kalifornien dass so viele
Ufos in den usa beobachtet werden das liegt sicher auch daran dass das projekt amerikanisch ist doch
Wo stalker ist nicht die einzige bank die sich auf die sichtung von
Außerirdischen spezialisiert hat es gibt auch deutsche web
zu diesem thema die ufo datenbank die gilt nach eigenen angaben, im deutschsprachigen raum als
zentrales archiv für
dokumentationen von gemeldeten ufo sichtungen in elektronischer form ihr selbsterklärtes
ziel ist es allen ufo interessenten eine möglichst große auswahl an
sichtungs berichten zur selbst recherche zur verfügung, zu stellen die ufo datenbank verweist
Im übrigen auch die grundsätze jeglicher wissenschaftlicher praxis in der erforschung des ufo phänomens auf der webseite heißt es unter anderem
Die erforschung des ufo phänomens geschieht in form
wissenschaftlich kritische arbeit offenheit für unterschiedliche sichtweisen sowie die bereitschaft die eigenen ergebnisse zu
hinterfragen mit anderen selbst kritisch zu diskutieren und unliebsame erkenntnisse zu akzeptieren gehören zur grundvoraussetzung
aller forscher neben dem sichtungs datum und derzeit liefert die website auch gleich eine beurteilung sowie wenn möglich eine
Identifikation mit so beispielsweise mit einer sichtung vom 19 08 und 2017 in ostfildern und zwar als ein ufo
also ein
identifizierbares fliegendes objekt in diesem fall waren es vögel ja wir haben hier ja so oft über künstliche intelligenz
Ki bericht den ich bin mal gespannt wenn eine solche software wie zum beispiel google brain die daten durchforstet
vielleicht kristallisieren sich dann wirklich echte sichtungen von raumschiffen
Heraus mal schauen wenn ihr kein video zu diesem thema und auch zu allen anderen dem verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier
ein abo aufsaugen vergessen nicht den
Auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr auch immer über neue videos informiert hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
Außerirdische revolution bei der suche da geht es auch. Um den einsatz von ki bei der suche nach außerirdischen ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran